how's it going there citizens of the reject
Nation we are here and it is time to check
out one of the most if not the most anticipated
show of the new year it's time for the last
of us but before we get to that I am joined
by the wonderful the incomparable our good
friend Tara Ericson Tara how are you today
I'm good you're good you're good good do you
know anything about this nothing nothing you
haven't played the game nope you've seen a
trailer nope cool this will be the noobs reaction
to the last of us I am very excited I have
also not played a lick of The Last of Us so
this could be completely fresh experience
as always if you could leave a like on this
video that would help a bunch that lets YouTube
know what you like and what's worth watching
as well hit that subscribe button and notification
Bell to get notified whenever something else
new comes out that you might enjoy as always
if you want to get the full experience with
us sync up with your own copy come on over
to patreon.com the real rejects watch The
Last of Us us alongside Terror and I alongside
Greg and Andrew as well as all the other bunch
of shows we got over there with reaction highlights
and watch alongs included that was so much
so fast John good job I did my best ring that
[Music] ring the bell I always do that on
here for the real rejects because it helps
you guys to ring the bell I know it like you
hear him ring the bell whatever but drop the
graphic in again yeah but then you hear me
singing you're like definitely subscribe definitely
I think we're I think that's I think we're
ready now um my soul is is on fire let's do
this let's watch the show [Applause]
and that's your biggest worry yes any kind
of virus but most probably something similar
to influenza
meaning all the whole world becomes sickle
at once oh so familiar many species know otherwise
because there are some fungi who seek not
to kill but to control like cordyceps or All
My Exes so it begins to devour its host from
within it keeps its puppet Alive by preventing
decomposition fungi cannot survive if it's
host's internal temperature is over 94 degrees
but what if that were to change the world
was to get slightly warmer well now there
is reason to evolve and there are no treatments
for this no preventatives no cures they don't
exist it's not even possible to make them
but none of this is going to happen I'm terrified
I'm like how much of this is based on actual
theoretical science I feel like probably a
lot of it and are we gonna see every single
one of those extras come back as a zombie
we might be dead in like two years creature
or whatever's about to come my God climate
change if we die I mean I'd be happy to be
zombies with you that would be fun or whatever
we become you know like a zombie virus rattled
hosts fungal controlled Meat Puppets [Music]
it's a beautifully disgusting Sim yeah this
is very cool [Music] it's like Game of Thrones
but with a virus yeah HBO's got a style
oh that's right what Craig Mason where's the
pancake mix what was that he's gonna make
you birthday pancakes I swear you know I don't
really like pancakes what Oberyn Martell doesn't
like pancakes is there enough for our uncle
Tommy I'm a what a man hey stay alive yo I'm
not splitting his job I barely want to split
it with you you could work a double today
I know I'd be done by nine by nine right p.m
bring back a cake I promise you better keep
that promise he's not gonna
wish I had that kind of cash when I was that
young yeah right it's like a treasure chest
oh it's not hers got it she's stealing I wish
I had a knife like that when I was that young
Connie was asking that for you I could come
by after school but just for like a little
bit but she'll take what you got foreign
I want one of those cat clocks
[Music]
oh I'm very sorry he cannot finish I'm already
finished he's home
yep just send her alone out into the world
yeah
it's the
math of salvation you're right there
oh
no
[Music] my dad's gonna be back real soon I
should go
uh oh she's not gonna be okay oh oh
the dog knows they always know yeah yeah it
was off so they're good at using backgrounds
and focus to drive up the Arenas the like
ominous like you know something's coming
Good Times ain't nothing bad gonna happen
today where's the cake
come on man let's get this one tomorrow you
don't get your present you got me a present
that's it
fixed it for you did you what oh
[Laughter]
far from the adlers oh this is the one with
the deleted scenes
me yeah but I'm in jail out now it's Friday
you don't get me out tonight I'm in here all
weekend oh boy
law enforcement and emergency services are
in the area and we'll be in contact with further
instructions oh my God let Mercy in though
yep oh my God yeah let her in
oh buddy
listen to the dog yeah please listen to the
dog
come on let's get you home
cool
oh no a little Mercy
Mrs Adler
foreign
[Music]
oh my god wow whoa
what are we doing Joe I mean nice hit
no no why why do people drop weapons why baby
I'm sorry Joe we gotta go upstairs listen
we're gonna be brave
let's go come on grab the wrench yeah I'm
so frustrated please grab the wrench uh Something's
Gonna no thank you [Applause] [Music]
whoa It's Jimmy's Place
oh no you can't help anybody
oh that sucks
and then they'll say that somebody else will
come along and then that's somebody else will
say that somebody else will come along
[Music] oh my God everybody's gonna cut through
the Mexico just far as far as we can how much
time to pick up the highway on the other side
of the blockade then we're out I'm so tense
right
what's up
oh that's why oh my God no are they headed
towards the air what the
[Music]
oh my God
what Jesus
are you serious just keep going oh my God
[Music] I have Goosebumps yeah
[__] move move
oh my God
[Music] a nightmare [Music]
are you okay are you okay we gotta get off
the street oh my God holy get out of here
Jones close on me okay you don't look anywhere
else
oh
yes
got the neck Creek oh God close the door oh
God oh no oh my God oh my God performance
on the show oh my I love the irony of chasing
them through a diner oh [Music] don't move
our two civilians by the river one of them
injured yes sir yes sir no uh okay yep yep
okay veteran combat make some moves now yeah
get closer we are not sick
good thing that hill was there I'm sorry please
stop oh my God
oh thank God my man Uncle Tommy MVP okay [Music]
what oh shoot oh my God
no I gotta get you up okay I gotta hit you
up I know baby no no I know I know I know
I know I know I know Tommy help me oh come
on come on come on come on
oh
what 20 years [Music] we got a [__] kid
over here
oh God okay wow I said seems fine closer it
is to your head it's gonna be a little tickle
right here
oh
what if I told you that after we gave you
some medicine we're gonna find you your favorite
food to eat and then we'll get you some new
clothes and toys as many as you want to play
with in heaven you're safe
body for the pile body for the pile ah
wow
oh
buddy God that's gonna be like PTSD for him
yeah
look good with the salt and pepper though
I hope he still has his watch and the battery
lasted 20 years
I wonder if that symbol was some kind of Easter
egg
oh my God
oh
come on now look more suspicious
prison rules hi Dro stay off the streets for
the next few nights bosses got us working
doubles guys are jumpy and tired stay safe
yeah you too ugh
in the darkness look for the light oh yeah
oh yeah I want you to forget this ever happened
done oh my gosh do uh you're so discipline
them I don't care they're your [__] guys
so I give you my word that he won't hurt you
so are we good oh my God
oh hello oh my God jeez [Laughter] e
oh my God
oh oh no oh [__] they're shooting at us
let's get our hands up dude oh my God
count slowly and clearly from one to ten one
two three
state your name slowly Veronica hey people
are gonna come looking for me people from
cedra you hear me let me out or you're gonna
pay mother woof all right I like her I'm on
her side dude her name's Veronica in clear
tribute to Resident Evil Code Veronica
nothing is there any chances coming in at
night when I'm sleeping Gabriella listens
or my son the smart one not the other one
Tommy responded we'd know when you're talking
to the Tower every day
all right it's the Cody Tower qbar4 but I
don't know exactly what [Music]
Craig Mason loves his deep focused particulate
shots
[Music] that's what I'm talking about and
now get a trench coat and put them each in
there oh heck yeah his watch is gonna be in
there yeah with the battery taken out and
then he's gonna put it back in I hope clever
girl [Music]
oh yeah take a drink every state line you
cross
oh that's too many that's always alcohol no
I was in Federal
oh damn Let's Go Hunt that mother down yeah
and get our battery and our truck and then
we'll go find Tommy yeah is a cutthro world
out here we are in a war against a military
dictatorship to restore democracy and freedom
to the son of our right Rebellion 's time
five or 20 years and you get nowhere you're
not a rebellion spray paint I want them as
distracted as possible because tonight every
Firefly in Boston is going to gather in this
building and we are going to leave the QC
we're taking that random girl locked in that
room West huh where are you gonna go back
to Federal military school they put me there
when I was a baby it's for Orphans they didn't
put you there United Ellie what
oh do you have a greater purpose than any
of us could have ever imagined but we're leaving
tonight and we're taking you with us is she
like immune is she like a carrier or something
what I'm about to tell you cannot be related
to anyone you do
this will go well foreign
what is that Jesus that's the virus whoa whoa
he came down after he was infected maybe down
here is where he was infected that is good
disgusting and beautiful yeah just like the
opening credit sure
smell that yeah gunpowder
oh good yes oh I was literally about to say
maybe your buddy killed himself or was killed
oh
damn that is an important car battery
oh interesting oh no I oh Marlene
the merch was bad and he obviously didn't
take my knife what do you need a car battery
for dope not at her oh whoa
she's special and now we all know it we're
gonna move Ellie out of the Zone tonight but
we won't make it anywhere like this not for
a while anyway you're gonna do it but now
I don't have a truck I don't have a squadron
Federer's five minutes away what I do have
is you and I know what you're both capable
of she seems desperate Firefly vehicle usually
means repurposed Venture stuff you all talk
it through but please remember that I'm bleeding
out she's great we'll go to your crew at the
state house but before we hand her over they
give us everything that we want if not we
kill her there and then deal that fast I want
to fill him in on exactly why she's so special
also I'd be like can I have your gun because
you're gonna die yeah maybe a couple guns
you just lost a whole Squadron you must have
some spare guys [Music]
is probably more before times culture than
you've seen in your whole life [Music] so
you're saying like wake me up before you go
go [Laughter] the 80s 80s means trouble code
broken
he went through that billboard book and found
the first 80 song you find look at the left
edge around the buffer zone you stay close
you follow my lead yeah yeah of course
it's not gonna go well I feel like we're gonna
see the little girl being more useful than
they think with her little knife
yeah she's going to take down a whole Squad
of fedra soldiers
I love how they have that Mantra about looking
for the light and now the light is like the
most threatening thing
let me put it back in real quick damn it oh
it's him it's a friend you're gonna be shitty
really man yep the game is by the book oh
no oh no no fine everything off of this run
and half off on all of the pills half off
all off out here in mine yes [__] okay
uh
don't no no oh [Music]
yeah oh no come on yeah he's gonna have to
beat him to death damn
bummer given the harsh circumstances I kind
of like that guy but also I get it he was
also the only help sort of oh yeah no no no
I'm not saying explain [__] I tell your
story Girl
take his gun it ain't Christ [Laughter]
[Laughter] it's
a fun needle drop
cool shot wow oh wow foreign
[Applause] [Laughter]
that
was that was so fun yeah insane and so good
I'm hooked and Dreadful and and ominous and
and so well fleshed out wow that's a PTSD
yeah yeah yeah a little bit of PTSD yeah yeah
oh boy well Tara Erickson yeah what did you
think video game expert Terrace yeah yeah
uh well just real quick last video game I
played was left for dead does that game still
exist that's how long ago did remember that
game I did oh in fact I've played a little
bit of leopard managed to play a little bit
every zombie game except this one such a good
game uh wow this was amazing great actors
great casting uh and oh yeah great story the
only thing I'm mad about is that he left the
wrench behind because I don't know I mean
that could have come in like why no like wipe
it off and put in your back pocket that's
like a weapon you could take you know come
on now don't worry in episode two he'll see
a different wrench he'll flash back to that
rent that will make me happy and also why
would you leave the only other thing why would
you leave the alcohol other than that this
is a brilliant show obviously I'm just saying
I got a couple of notes you gotta get the
yeah you gotta get the major complaints out
of the way before we heat praise upon them
a couple of notes that's it that's about it
everything else Wow real good yeah have you
did you see Chernobyl yeah yeah this is the
same Creator show runner I mean you know Neil
druckman who uh you know did the game and
all that stuff not solely obviously to oversimplify
Neil druckman is like the major uh you know
contributor to the game working on the show
but yeah Craig Mason is yeah the guy who did
Chernobyl among other things and like Chernobyl
was pretty incredible to my viewing experience
and I thought you know like okay it seems
like a good choice for you know the vague
amounts I've collected over time about what
this world is supposed to be but yeah like
the way that this fleshes out the situation
and lets you live inside of it and and really
kind of puts you in a uniquely there's like
a unique blend of like very realistic grittiness
but also this sort of like ethereal sort of
melancholy that that you know touches everything
and uh yeah like again I don't really know
how to I can't compare this as an adaptation
but this does feel this has to be like I I
can only imagine people are going to be like
this is the best video game because this does
completely feel cinematic yeah if this was
a video game I would play it which I guess
it is but it left me wondering I'm like whoa
so what's the game like you're just going
around negotiating and like trying to get
car batteries and like occasionally having
to shoot something but mostly just like dealing
with the aftermath of society oh and uh hydrocodone
too yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah filtering for
drugs pilfering pills I kind of want to be
the guy in this video game or in the show
that is just making bullets and making pills
right because that's chill you're like you
pop one you're chilling you're making bullets
making pills nobody wants to kill you because
they're like you are important yeah and I
need pills I need to yeah I need to go numb
and I need tall summer or something yes yeah
well we'll get to what do they say Atlanta
you know oh yeah maybe because I I have to
imagine if they're traveling outside of the
quarantine Zone we're only that's only gonna
get worse and we're only gonna spend more
time away from what should be an easy destination
yes she didn't pick back up her knife that's
another thing right because she did she stab
the guy at the end in the leg with her knife
I think the shooter guy right I think she
did I mean in the hallway scene she goes back
into the room to get her a bag but I think
because he kicks it up the hall but but we
didn't see her like maybe they just we'll
see it and what knife was that I'm mad when
they don't get weapons back these are the
importance these are important I'm learning
a lot of things about your tastes taste as
a viewer it's good never leave a weapon anytime
ever ever you're the character in the video
game who's like why can't I hold more like
I imagine you're playing a video game if there's
like DLC you're like you're just always throwing
down for the expanded inventory yes there's
hundreds of items because you just said they're
going it's gonna get worse and I'm like yes
and you want to see her do some stuff with
her knife she's a tough girl but then I'm
like did she leave it behind I hope she didn't
she couldn't he at least
yes he did yeah she also knows how to kick
butt you know like she's like right she went
to military school for a minute it's gonna
be good yeah it's gonna be good well dude
like the way like they really had me going
because like that Pro you know like I feel
like it's a it's a classic type of I keep
calling it zombie but I guess the more apt
term would be like infection outbreak thing
but like yeah you know you have your sort
of prologue where you're like ah yeah you're
like in society and everything's normal and
then we meet like a family but only one of
them is or the whole family's not gonna make
it through and I thought the way that they
did the whole prologue was really intense
and affecting and like they really got me
invested in Sarah especially the his actual
daughter oh yeah and that whole like mad rush
through the city where they're in the card
it's not like one hole there are a lot of
long takes not one whole take but the way
they captured them in the car from mostly
just that perspective like it hit me part
way through I was like we have not left this
car and I am so short of breath because it
feels like you are kind of in the midst of
it and I Marvel at the idea that you know
after so many of you know this kind of thing
something can still feel as fresh and vital
in depicting you know the the the the day
Society collapsed you know as as this felt
and then the subsequent time Jump you know
and they did a good job with just the very
subtle like the bumper sticker of like he's
a combat veteran so you know that they're
they have to prep they'll make it right but
you you don't see it coming when they're it's
like safety in that car with that logo and
them being tough but you do not expect her
to be ripped from that situation so quickly
uh again just like the the I this you know
the happenstance is so heartbreaking because
yeah it is one of those things where you can
you encounter one soldier and if you know
you don't handle the situation right or they
get the right order you know like things are
gonna go south and yeah the way they captured
that like God and I also thought this is not
it but I was like could Marlene be that girl
who died her mom like 20 years I was like
they never established who the little girl's
mom was yeah and when I saw Marlene come in
like being tough and I'm like well there was
no pictures either in the house yeah of what
the mom looked like but now the mom's dead
so it wouldn't be they wouldn't set that up
for like Marlene to bleed out and die because
she was sure if she died she had one of those
wounds that you that those are like she's
standing and she's like completely over here
you know like I think she'll be okay okay
then I'm gonna I'm gonna keep that in a side
pocket and say Marlene could maybe be revealed
to be the little girl who died her mom all
right did a thing one time you know but Marlene
was like I gotta get out of here can't have
the kid you get it that's why they know each
other okay I'm done now she walked out on
them both damn she's like I gotta do military
stuff that's right she's even in normal society
I gotta lead the Rebellion I gotta you know
reinstate democracy and her rescuing the girl
is her like making up for leaving her child
I got it all figured out just like the show
put me in the room you know the writer's room
don't just need to watch more episodes but
you just did it yeah you should be writing
season two I don't want to just let me be
in it yeah no I mean this would be this would
be one of those dream shows where it's like
even if you just show up for like an episode
to be a female character who will then be
killed or something I've been under I'm okay
with it right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so let me up uh yeah I mean and the casting
across the board like Pedro Pascal I think
is great um I love I I hope we see those Diego
Luna I think as as Uncle Tommy like I I love
it he'll be back yeah like I hope to see him
again and uh and yeah like there are a bunch
of other actors who like you recognize and
were some of them from Chernobyl because I'm
bad at recognizing that but I'm like Chernobyl
also it totally makes sense when she brought
that up was such a brilliantly acted TV show
that and that's just like uh I love it when
shows are like I believe everything that is
coming out of everyone's mouth and that is
not normally the case always yeah and like
the like everybody really plays everything
with a very lived in quality like you know
I feel like in a show like this or a movie
that you know is doing post-apocalypse and
stuff like that I feel like there can be in
the dialogue a certain amount of like posturing
whereas here everybody does just feel like
this is the day in day out like the lines
are thrown away in just the right ways where
you're like yeah no I can tell you're sick
of this [__] and you can't give out too
much information and so you know like that
scene where um Marlene is with her like lieutenant
or you know the other woman who's helping
her and then she sends the other two guards
away it's like yeah it's like the first time
we're meeting the both of you but I'm just
like fully invested in like the conflict that
you're dealing with and how I know you can't
like Marlene can't give up too much information
because clearly no one in this world is very
trustworthy for good reason right and the
way even just that they draw that Society
like I loved meeting oh what is her name Tess
in in that moment where you know she's bargaining
to get out of this uh oh yeah yeah the the
two guys roughed her up and she's like bargaining
to get out of that situation and then immediately
tells Joel about it and they go back to find
him so good yeah and just like the chain of
events because you know it it made this for
this really nice feeling that just the plot
is unfolding and every plan leads to you know
every step of the plan kind of diverts in
a New Direction because the situation is such
a mess that I have to imagine no plan is really
like foolproof or not subject to a lot of
variables that could change it up and it feels
it it nicely feels like a world where yeah
they just kind of have to deal with whatever
[__] situation they're dealt at the time
rather than feeling like oh the plot demands
that such and such a thing happens right and
I feel like in that situation Marlene and
her like Lily I forget what that girl her
name was not Lily when they're in the room
she sends the two guards out just in the way
they say their names to each other she's like
Ellie and she's like Marlene like it's just
so it's great and it's already established
like great we're they're a little bit closer
than the rest yeah we get that and just with
one word it's like bro you gotta open up to
me now because this is some [__] uh which
I really I really like but it's the same thing
with Tess when she was with the guy it was
already Within a sentence or two establish
like that they kind of knew each other and
there was a way that they were gonna sort
of bargain for her to maybe get out of there
yeah that scene was really really enjoyable
yeah and very funny hilarious this whole show
is Left Right but yeah and and like I love
that little prologue I wonder if we'll see
probably not I have to imagine but I wonder
if we'll see like you know they got John Hannah
and Chris overdahl and that guy from Silicon
Valley in the opening scene where they're
really laying out like here's a discussion
of exactly the situation we're about to deal
with and uh and yeah too just I don't know
there's so many nice little flavors across
this that it I have to imagine that now by
the end of this episode everything is set
and and we're you know striking out into the
unknown the ruins of society but I have a
feeling that that'll be kind of you know this
episode gave us a few different times and
places to deal with before you know sending
us off into the main part of the story and
I also love that you know this is coming out
of a horror like a survival horror game you
expect yeah there will be a lot of you know
horror set pieces and infected creatures to
deal with and I like the way they handled
the Restraint of that for this episode as
well because you get certainly intensity and
violence in moments of you know a huge chaos
and Peril but we really have yet to see the
full scope of the actual infection at work
you know you see that guy baked into the wall
and everything but how did he get that way
that's a thing and they're like he they probably
got it down there right but they're not answering
there's we still don't know then why are you
not running out of there yeah they must they
know something that we don't like how do you
get it how do you get the virus oh I love
that too the whole like you know if it's on
your your head or your face it'll be like
15 to 20 minutes yes yeah it's like it's like
an arm it'll be like an hour if it's like
your foot like 12 hours yeah yeah they're
really great at laying in details and building
the world in a way that doesn't feel like
we're getting like the moments where you have
like that argument between Marlene and her
general or whatever like that's a bit of exposition
but it felt very well motivated by like the
frustration between the two of them and I
think that for a lot of the stuff they have
to lay out they're really good at making it
feel like something characters would naturally
be talking about rather than telling rather
than setting up a reason to info dump the
audience yes and so it seems like something
you do have to pay a certain amount of attention
to because they're not just going to force
feed you everything but it also seems like
if you're really paying attention it's all
there you know yeah yeah I hate shows that
are like overly ex expository that's not is
that that is right I said it right people
yeah okay like a good like Exposition in a
show but none of this felt that way to me
except for yeah the setup of like how we need
the girl out we're gonna use her right and
we need to move but that was more like oh
yeah like okay cool like I didn't feel I felt
good about it I was like I didn't feel like
it was exposition of us already knowing that's
the thing I hate it when we already know something
and then they feel like they gotta double
check and let us know in words what we already
know yeah uh I hate that and they didn't do
that and then so I'm I like me likey Yeah
Yeah man they left us off on a little note
of trouble I love that too I love the code
with the radio yeah and I was trying to figure
out is it 70 so it's new because 60s is old
was that a 70s Vibe and there's like something
new is coming in because I feel like that
girl did decode stuff but that was like yeah
I don't know was it any I feel like the last
song must have been an 80s song for to signify
this onset of more trouble okay I mean we
already knew that we're sure we knew more
trouble maybe it's like there's more trouble
now there's something new on top of the trouble
new trouble and there's no way we can find
out what era the song was from no there's
no way I like rewind it let me Shazam it real
quick yeah that's right that's right Shazam
will sometimes I've tried shazaming things
from TV on occasion and instead of bringing
me just the song it'll bring you to the episode
of TV yeah and you're like thanks that's not
what I'm trying to do when it does that yeah
I'm like I need to know the song and the artist
to go and listen to this song forever and
always in my vehicle and when it gives me
like this is from the show just listen to
the show in your car and and you know try
not to be distracted but yeah I love the world
they set up here and and I feel like you know
we're venturing out from there so we're not
going to spend all the time in the camp but
even like the camp was super interesting and
now I just can't wait to see what lies Beyond
so uh I think we did it was there you got
any more stray thoughts oh did anybody else
leave a weapon behind oh yeah I already said
it in there he should have taken her gun because
she was bleeding out but like we said she's
gonna come back she'll be back and then that
girl is gonna look cool with one ear she is
right that's gonna be she's gonna look so
badass yeah so yeah I'm stoked on all of it
yeah me too well guys leave us your thoughts
leave us uh don't spoil anything if your Gamers
out there you can go comment on Greg and Andrew's
video not ours so don't you know we we ask
respectfully that you share your enthusiasm
Enlighten us on anything pertinent to this
first episode but uh yeah no game spoilers
or anything like that we would like to preserve
the surprise of this experience us noobs gotta
stick together so uh thanks for joining us
if you joined us and hey let's let's send
this off with a patron of the day shout outs
that's all good yeah
Gabriel I'm choosing you because Gabriel Luna
is in the show and I love Gabriel Luna Gabriel
oh Gabriel oh you're cool Gabriel oh [Music]
yeah yeah it's not in a LOL he's in a high
cause he supports a big tree on that's the
end of my song cause it was really bad
wish I was more talented when it came to improvising
songs dude it's hard right it's hard it's
hard but Gabriel you know what's not hard
appreciating you being a part of our patreon
page I hope that you like spooky things you
know we always hope you know because it's
always a little bit random who makes it onto
a shout out but I hope that this is the show
that's up your alley so that we can share
in this together so that you didn't have to
sit through I don't know if you notice you
can't skip ahead on YouTube so you just have
to sit through you know 40 minutes or so of
us yammering and reacting to get to his Shadows
so Gabriel thank you for your patience and
uh stay safe out there don't take don't contract
any odd infections you know oh and don't leave
your weapons behind Gabriel you have one job
to do and and staying pledged to the patreon
yeah I mean indefinitely would you say don't
leave your weapons behind man we don't I don't
want to get mad
at you or friends doing Gabriel me and you
are friends out you know unless you're leaving
weapons for us to find yeah yeah sure sure
like I scavenge your amount of weapons I would
love that dude you're good Gabriel thank you
for the scavenger hunt thank you so much buddy
love you [Music]